it's gonna be a beautiful wedding
here you are standing on the precipice
of something so much bigger than anyone
here but always remember you are not
alone I don't think that we met I'm Sara
Niles hi
[Music]
[Music]
it's gonna be a beautiful wedding good
day so far today tomorrow it's all the
same yeah what is going on
guess he followed me it's one of those
infinite time live situations you might
have heard about dad I might have heard
about yeah the second you fall asleep it
all just goes back to the start I drove
all the way back home to Austin and I
still woke up here one time I smoked a
bunch of crystal and made it all the way
to Equatorial Guinea it was a huge waste
attack
well then what's the point of living we
kind of have no choice but to live you
know I'm gonna get out of this suit
yourself so now what do we do you just
have to embrace the fact that nothing
matters do you sleep with people in here
great question
I have but it takes a lot of work may I
cut in
it's the first dance and that's a deal
breaker that didn't work let's waste
some time
Oh dance
nobody's officiant you got a bag of
sweets in this pocket you're right
[Music]
everything that we are doing is
meaningless at least you have each other
nothing worse than going through this
[ __ ] alone
[Music]
there's a bomb in the cake don't worry I
used to be a bomb guy
[Applause]
[Music]